what does our final shot of Stanley
Kubrick's a shining really mean and what
happens to the traumatized characters
left alive it's time to talk about those
questions and dig up some answers in
order to survive the events of the
shining Danny Torrance was forced to
escape his own father in a freezing
hedge maze and flee a haunted hotel
where he'd seen enough freaky surf to
Serie C mess up even your average adult
[Music]
play with us daddy so while he lived to
tell the tale it's tough to imagine
Danny has a normal life waiting for him
in the aftermath if he want to go with
Stephen King's version of events Danny's
future is at least partially written in
the 2013 novel dr. sleeper King's
official sequel to The Shining a grown
Danny Torrance suffers from alcoholism
like his father Danny gets a job at a
nursing home where he's able to help
guide the dying into the next realm
he eventually encounters a girl with
abilities like his own and fights to
save her from a group of psychic
vampires sounds strange
dr. sleep is headed for the big screen
in late 2019 so you can see it for
yourself the most debated element of the
Shining's ending is a final shot showing
jack in the photo of the overlooks 1921
fourth of July party which could mean a
few things it could be that in death
Jack has been absorbed into the
overlooks history and now walks the
haunted world where all errors seem to
be happening at once it could also be
that the photo is the hotel's way of
showing that Jack's descent into madness
was a fulfillment of some kind of
twisted destiny one particular
interpretation has been adopted by many
of the film's hardcore fans the
overlooks long series of caretaker
murders and the fact that it was built
on an Indian burial ground suggests that
the hotel is a place where history
repeats itself many believe Jack was a
reincarnated soul who was always meant
to be part of that cycle he was destined
to return to the hotel and recreate its
bloody past according to the theory this
is what the spectral Grady means during
the conversation in the red bathroom
when he tells Jack you if you watch The
Shining all the way through get to that
final shot of Jack in the photo and then
we watch it you won't notice something
that stands out about the Overlook there
were framed black-and-white photos
chronicling the hotel's history
everywhere dozens of them more than
identical frames all covering the
hotel's illustrious history if Jack was
a reincarnation of a past guests or
caretaker and he was always on the photo
how long will it be before someone
notices in there and if he's there it
stands to reason that Grady would be
there too proving he was also a victim
of the cycle of reincarnation and
violence if the fallout from the latest
Overlook tragedy goes on long enough
photos will likely mean something to
someone and that will set off an
entirely different kind of investigation
early in the shining when dick Halloran
sits down with Danny to explain to him
what the shining is he tells the boy
that he's not alone but there are the
folk who mostly don't believe it
considering both Halloran and Danny two
of the rare souls of this psychic gift
find themselves in the Overlook does
this mean that in the world of the
shining people of the gift that drawn to
places with powerful supernatural
presences or are they able to sense the
spirits present wherever they are the
film only scratches the surface but his
dick draws closer to his violent end
Danny's journey is just beginning you've
got the Shh you wanna get sued The
Shining is a film about cyclic or
violence and about how he can't escape
the dark specter of history the Overlook
is built on the Sacred Lands of Native
Americans who were slaughtered in the
name of expansion and blood continues to
spill there Jack Torrance says own
history with violence doesn't begin in
the Overlook but years before when he
heard his son during a drunken binge
that's why when Wendy sees Danny injured
she immediately assumes it was Jack you
hurt him
just as the Overlook uses Jack to
continue its own bloody tradition it
traps him back in his own past when
drinking allows him to cross the line
into violence but this time the stakes
are much higher than a broken bone or
two I'm just gonna bash your brains like
Jack the Overlook has its own grisly
cycle first the Native Americans killed
for its creation Grady murdering his
family and now Jack attempting to
slaughter his wife and son it's quite
possible there were others we never
heard about fortunately Wendy and Danny
escaped the hotel relatively unscathed
at least physically does this mean that
through their survival they've somehow
broken the cycle does this mean that
overlooks evil sway is at least somewhat
lessened the film doesn't make the
answer clear but there is hope check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]